ま）ワイにも１個くれ。
は）いやいやいや→
こんちゃー
は）はい皆さんハンドスピナー
ま）はい
ま）ふふｗたの、楽しいね
は）実際にやると→
ええわ
ま）ンフ、アハハ///
は）なんかこうやっぱ退屈しのぎになるんですよね回ってるだけで→
回転するだけでも十分面白いことは十分に俺はもう分かった理解した→
その上でいいます→
もっと別の楽しみ方があるんじゃねぇかと思いまして→
一回回しまーす→
よーいドン
は）これでだいたいどれくらい回るのか一回見てみましょう
は）はい！→
１分３３秒ぐらいは回転しますね→
回転させて一分半ぐらいも回るってなかなか無いとおもうんで→
これ僕思ったんですけど→
こうやって一個回すじゃん？地面において→
もう一個こうやっておいて回すジャン？→
んでこれもう一個おいて回すじゃん?→
まわすじゃん→
きれいじゃね！？→
すごいよね？命の輝きを感じるというかさ
は）まぁこういう風にハンドスピナー回転させるやつを重ねていくと→
ハンドスピナーの塔が出来ます→
名付けて→
あび～～～～～～～～～～～
ま）名付けてあび～～～～～～～～～～～
は）名付けてハンドスピナータワー→
今勝手につけたんですけども→
ハンドスピナーなぜみんな見ちゃうかというと→
はまっちゃうかというと回転してるからなんですよ→
こう動きがずっと続いてるからみんな興味を示してこうじっと見てるんで→
それをたくさん重ねていくともっといいんじゃねぇか→
ね？みんな一個で満足してるんでしょ？→
チッチッチッチ→
なので今回はこの回転してるハンドスピナーを重ねていって→
ハンドスピナータワーをなるべく高くしていこうと思います→
目標何段くらい？→
ま）10はいけそうだもんね
は）10はいけるたぶん
ま）20じゃない？
は）じゃあ
ま）うん。
は）そんな簡単でいいの？20でいいの？おい→
30いこう30→
全部ちゃんと回転してる状態で30こ重ねて→
30cmぐらいのハンドスピナータワーを作り出して→
みんなに感動してもらおうという
ま）いい企画だね
は）いい企画純粋に
ま）ねぇ。
は）これだと小学生もみてくれるかな？
は）今俺の家には1000個のハンドスピナータワーがあるから→
あわよくば１０００個行けるからね→
よしっでは我々のハンドスピナーを全部使ってやっていきましょう！→
じゃ行きます→
よーいスタート
ま）ふふふふふふふｗｗ
ま）9…
は）うみゃぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ‼‼‼‼‼→
もう一回やっていい？→
床にしっかり置くことが大事だよね
ま）３
は）ずれたずれた
は）ちょっとずれてる
ま）微妙にずれてる
ま）６
は）やばいきつい
ま）7…ちょっとこうなってる
は）こっちか→
やばいやばいやばい青が青が青が青が青がヤバい
ま）9
は）えっなんで？そんなに早いか？
は）あ、駄目だこの子だめだ駄目だこの子駄目だ駄目だ→
ヤバい青が止まる！→
あーこれゲームオーバーっすね→
これ２０も難しいねたぶん
ま）んー２０けっこうむずいね
ま）ア～はいっ
は） は）どう？
は）3
ま）あーちょっと弱かった
は）ンアーッ！wwwwww→
いやー難しい２段目から難しい
は）9おおいいよいいよ
は）16
は）いいよーいいよ！
は）イヤーチョットマッテチョットマッテ→
あ、まだ大丈夫まだ大丈夫あ、あああああおまお、おまおま→
まだ大丈夫まだまだ→
あ、全体的に駄目だね
ま）20
は）これ復元あり？
ま）あり
は）復活アリね。あ、まだ生きてるいきてる
ま）めっちゃ揺れてるー
は）すごいすごいすごい→
ああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああ!!!!→
wwwww
ま）惜しいwww
は）ちょっといくつか分かったことあるな→
まず回転力が難しいね→
たぶん12,3段ぐらいいくと失速してくるんでそこが難しいのと→
純粋に高くなってくるとバランスがとりにくい→
なら20段行けそうな気がするね
ま）20頑張ればいけるねこれ
は）頑張っていってみましょう。いきます→
用意スタート
は）はい！→
ま）これ難しいんすよ!?
ま）ほんとに
は）難しい難しい
は）18!?→
アアアイミイイイイイッ
ま）ずれた
ま）その合わせ方ある？ｗ
は）はッはッはッできた！できた！できた！できた！やったぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！！！
・・・
♪～